Well, I've been pretty busy. Met
a girl at SoHo house.
-Was she your waitress?
-Yes.
Then I met a girl at Mastro's.
-Was she also your waitress?
-Yes.
Then I met a girl
at P.F. Chang's.
-Let me guess. She was your--
-A hooker, yes.
-But what she really wants to do
is wait tables.
-(LAUGHS)
So I'm sending
the first draft of the book
to Pinky this afternoon.
-What? It's done?
-Not yet. Almost.
I'm excited for you to read it,
but I'm also
cripplingly nervous.
I actually kind of feel
like throwing up,
but I can't throw up
because I haven't had
anything to eat
because this lady
won't let me in my own kitchen.
Cast and crew only.
Listen, if reading a book
you wrote
is anywhere near as great
as it is to actually spend time
with you,
I'm sure
it's gonna be wonderful.
Having said that,
what do I know about books?
I'm just a dumb actor.
I'm here with Hollywoo darling,
Naomi Watts.
Tell me, what attracted you
to the role of Diane?
I just keep getting pigeonholed
as these complex characters
in highly acclaimed movies.
For once, I would just love
to phone it in
and play a two-dimensional girl
in a rom com
with no inner life of her own.
Ha-ha! You said words.
Now, is it true
you stay in character
between takes?
Oh, we all do.
The director insists upon it.
He even has everyone
calling me Diane
to help me get in the headspace.
Diane, looking good.
-Um, thanks.
-Ugh, not you.
-I was talking to Diane.
-Oh, thank you.
-Now, where's my peanut butter?
-Right over here, Q.
-No, I'm looking
for peanut butter.
-Oh, you mean BoJack?
If I wanted BoJack,
I would call BoJack.
Did someone call for BoJack?
It really cuts down
on confusion.
Aloha, kemosabe.
Hey, allow me
to put on my producer hat
and produce you
just for one second here.
I have a few notes
on how you're playing me.
Let's see. Here we go.
I find it really troubling
that my movie self
is wearing a crew-neck T-shirt.
(LAUGHS)
-You see the problem.
-I do not.
I just think
if we're telling the story,
we should tell it
how it really happened.
Yeah, this whole story
isn't how it really happened.
Right...
because of the shirts.
Because I'm the one
who stole the D.
I'm the real hero here.
My life is full
of exciting adventures.
I should write a book.
Oh, wait. I did.
Hey, you're in a mood.
Perhaps the tightness
of that crew neck is cutting off
circulation to the brain?
Let me talk to Donna
in wardrobe.
Donna!